[Music]
my name is Maxine I'm talking about
functional data engineering and a set of
best practices that are related to this
functional approach here I'm using the
term functional as in functional
programming so I'm gonna get much more
into that but before I do I want to set
a little bit of the context for this
talk so first thing a little bit about
me but though pretty much everything's
been said so I work at lift before
working at lift I was at Airbnb Facebook
Yahoo and Ubisoft and while I was at
Airbnb I started to open-source projects
that are now incubating at a patchy
software foundation so the first one is
about you air flow it sounds like people
in the room are already pretty familiar
with Apache airflow air flow is a
workflow engine it's a tool to help you
author schedule monitor your data
pipelines it's largely inspired by
something at Facebook called data swarm
and it has gotten super popular over the
past few years since then so I've been
writing a lot more JavaScript lately so
it's rare that you see someone who
writes a lot of JavaScript speak at a
data engineering conference but I guess
it's happening now so superset is a data
visualization platform dashboarding data
exploration and all that good stuff so
if you haven't heard about it I urge you
to take a look it's getting really good
superset has engineers from Airbnb lyft
Twitter and Apple collaborating and the
project is really taking off at the
moment no good
we've got Apple asking me to do
something with USBC and I will say not
now thank you not the right time all
right cool so this this talk today is
about a blog post that I wrote recently
that's called functional data
engineering modern prior down for batch
data processing this stick plot takes
place in a content in the context of a
few blog posts that I wrote
past few years the first blog post that
I wrote about data engineering was
called the rise of the data engineer and
it was about trying to really understand
what is the data engineering role where
does that fit in relation to data
science Data Platform engineering what
does that fit in relation to historical
jobs and titles like business
intelligence engineer data warehouse
architect so this is what this post is
about if you're a data engineering you
haven't read the post
I would pry urge you to take a look and
and to read this pose so I really tried
to make kind of a manifesto for what did
engineering is and then over the years I
became a little bit more jaded about
data engineering and you know I just
realized it's really sometimes an
ungrateful work to be a data engineer
the tooling is really hard it's a space
that moves really fast it's a role
that's really underappreciated hopefully
other people are going to talk at the
conference about that and about solving
these problems but so yes I wrote all
about kind of the the hardships of being
a data engineer nowadays and then more
recently as I said I started writing a
lot more JavaScript for Apache superset
and I got so there's this thing in the
JavaScript community where people are
getting really into the functional
programming paradigm so I drank the
kool-aid I got interested in functional
programming and I drawn a lot of
parallel between the best practices that
we use at places like Facebook and
Airbnb with the functional programming
paradigm and this is what I'm about to
talk about today so that some of that
stuff is old news I see some of my ex my
colleagues from Airbnb at Facebook and
for some of them and like some of that
stuff may sound like total total old
news so there might be a little bit of a
sense of like of course you know you
don't have to tell people this everyone
knows that stuff but that's not always
true so as I joined lyft I realized that
a lot of the best practices I took for
granted in places like Facebook and
Airbnb we're not necessarily respected
or they're not common knowledge also
count on the road show for air flows
I've been visiting a lot of companies
talking about open source talking about
floo and i also realized that in those
places those best practices were not
coming knowledge as well so so I was
like let's write a blog post about this
use that as some sort of manifesto again
as to a set like a way an approach to
doing things and and then you know maybe
talk at conferences about it in here I
am so before I get into functional data
engineering I want to get into
functional programming so I'm sure a lot
of people in the room here are like
fairly familiar with object-oriented
programming and that's what if thought
in schools I'm sure you know pretty much
although the engineers in the room would
be able to describe describe
object-oriented programming functional
programming is just an alternate
approach it's a different paradigm it's
a different way to think about
structuring and organizing your code I'm
not going to read the whole definition
here from the wiki video page because I
didn't come here to read Wikipedia
articles but I'm gonna raise a few
points that I think are most relevant
and most interesting and most relatable
to data engineering so I'm gonna start
by reading from just one line for from
the Wikipedia article that says in
functional code the output value of a
function depends only on the arguments
that are passed to the function so
calling the function twice with the same
input will result in the same output so
that brings me to the concept of a pure
function so pure functions and
functional programming are functions
that are limited to their own scope so
so that means that given the same out
same input it will provide the same
output that's a nice guarantee it's
easier to reason about there's no side
effects you can easily unit test these
functions and that brings clarity to the
process right just knowing that this
function is limited to its scope is a
nice guarantee to have another concept
in functional programming is
immutability if the immutability is
foundational to two functional
programming and the idea that in pure
functional languages you won't be able
to
to reassign a variable so variable
there's a constant once a variable has
been assigned you cannot reassign it
once you create an object this object is
immutable if you want to modify the
object you're gonna have to somehow
create a new object and effect it to a
new constant and because of that it
completely changes the way you code and
the way you think about your code if you
see a variable that's been affected you
know it will stay the same within that
scope so I think this translates and
I'll get into how this translate into
some concepts in data engineering in
just a moment another key concept in
functional programming is idempotent see
idempotence is the property of certain
operations in mathematics and computer
science that they can be applied
multiple times without changing the
result beyond the initial application so
that means if you have a function that's
idempotent you can run it one time you
can run it two times you can run it n
times you'll get to the same desired
state with confidence but a simple kind
of stupid example of that would be if I
write a function that says add a little
bit of water to this glass that is not
an idempotent function if I keep running
this function at some point the glass of
water is going to spill right and if if
instead of doing that that I write a
function that says fill up the glass
with water and fill no more that's an
item post and function that can run at
any point in time and get to a desired
state without spillage so now I'm going
to talk a little bit about functional
data engineering or try to apply some of
the concepts I just talked about and how
they map into the data engineering world
here when I say data engineering I'm
mostly thinking about like batch
computation so you know I'm a batch guy
because I wrote airflow I wrote the at
least the first version of air flow and
I'm thinking also mostly from a data
warehousing perspective I know data
engineering is not just batch it's also
streams and it's not just data where
they're data warehousing it's all sorts
of computation the concepts I'm talking
about today certainly do apply to data
where else
batch processing and in many cases will
apply to streams and to other types of
computation they may or they may not so
the first thing I want to mention is
some of the motives for this myth the
methodology that I'm talking about
functional data engineering is
reproducibility so as you know
reproducibility is foundational to the
scientific method right if you if you're
scientist and you make some great claims
and you write an article with
outstanding results your peers need to
be able to reproduce your results of our
science as not advanced by an inch right
so reproducibility is sometimes as legal
also for a minute from the critical from
a legal standpoint it might be critical
for a miss sanity standpoint or if
you're there in a bit engineer and you
you write some jobs you run some jobs
and you run the same job today as you
ran yesterday and you get different
results you'll probably go a little bit
insane over time maybe you're probably
already a little bit insane if you're a
data engineer anyways but you know you
don't want to make it worse so so this
this functional approach that I'm
talking about today is all about
reproducibility and kind of sanity too
so a mutable partition side I talked
about a little bit of you know about
immutable and amiability being a key
concept in functional programming in the
data warehouse you can think of
partitions or immutable partitions as
the building block of your building
blocks of your data warehouse all right
so partitions become kind of the
foundation to your data warehouse the
equivalent of nubile objects and because
you don't want to mutate anything you
can't need to add these partitions into
your warehouse one at a time and you
have to probably partition all of your
tables because you don't want to mutate
your tables you don't want to change
them every day right you want to you
want to essentially partition everything
you want your ETL schedule to align with
your partitioning scheme so that I mean
if you're running daily jobs or hourly
jobs you should have daily partitions
and pretty much all of your tables and
when you think about this
I'm sure when you guys think about they
love lineage if I say the word data
lineage and you close your eyes you
probably see this graph of tables right
you think my data lineage is this graph
of tables but when you use partitioning
you can start thinking of data lineage
as a graph of partitions so that means
that the mental model is a little bit
extended here and if you think say of
any given row and say that partition in
sales aggregation here in this table any
row you can easily attach to the
partition that it's in and any partition
you can kind of infer it's data lineage
therefore having this provenance
traceability reproducibility and all
that good stuff now pure ETL tasks so
earlier I mentioned pure functions in
functional programming pure ETL tasks
are simply tasks that are ident right so
if you rerun them you're safe you know
you're gonna get to the desired state
this is great in distributed systems you
say you have an airflow cluster or you
have any form of large computation that
are distributed taking place if anything
fails halfway you don't know if it
succeeded if it ran if it failed you
know that you can always get back to the
state where you want to be by rerunning
this idempotent task
there's deterministic giving the same
source partitions they will produce the
same target partition they have no side
effect they use immutable sources they
usually target a single partition so
they're easy to reason about and that
also means that you're never doing
update absurd append delete you're
essentially inserting new partitions all
the time or you are insert overwriting
partitions so of course that doesn't
mean that you should never do this type
of operations up there update absurd
append elite but if you want a pure kind
of functional data warehouse you
probably want to always insert overwrite
a new object or a new partition and in
general you probably want to limit the
number of party
of source partition that you're scanning
just for the sake of simplicity and
trying to keep your computation units
fairly simple and I'll talk a little bit
about a little bit more about that later
one thing I want to talk about is this
idea of a persistent staging area so the
term staging area if you read any of the
books about data warehousing from like
fifteen or twenty years ago you you'll
realize it's not a new term the idea of
a staging area is the place where all of
your data that makes it into your data
warehouse would at some point make it
through your staging area usually your
staging area is not transformed at all
so you'd bring the raw ingredients from
your external sources into your
warehouse pretty much untransformed and
you know in the old books about data
warehousing they would debate whether
you should have a persistent or a
transient staging area and nowadays you
know within like pretty much infinite
cheap storage I would argue that you
probably want to almost in all cases
have a persistent staging area so that
means any time you bring data from
external systems you would load it into
your warehouse untransformed and leave
it there forever essentially right so
there might be some exceptions you might
have some very high volume low value
data that you might want to you know
compress in some way but in general I
would just argue to bring that in your
warehouse you know make it immutable put
it into read optimized file format like
Parker or or C and leave it there
forever knowing that your data is or
this raw data your staging area is this
the raw ingredients and knowing that you
probably have all of your
transformations or recipe you know you
can get you can get you can rebuild a
whole warehouse from your raw data and
your computation at any point in time
and knowing how common backfills are
it's a really nice assumption to have
cool so now I'm going to get into like
some set of comments and solutions so
these are common challenges around
data processing vegetative processing
data warehousing in general and
solutions that are you know solve in
this functional approach to data
engineering and bear with me here I'm
about to get into something a little bit
complicated here it's this idea of
slowly changing dimension so who here
has heard or would say like they're they
know pretty well what's staging the
slowly change and dimensions are all
about yeah yeah yeah that works I think
if you if you read the Wikipedia article
that totally counts - so here in the old
books about data warehousing so ralph
kimball in the lifecycle the data
warehouse toolkit I believe wrote about
it originally slowly changing dimension
is this idea that in dimensional
modeling right if you're going to use
fact tables and dimension tables to
model your business data and typically
your business entities entities you will
model as dimensions the attributes to
your dimension members are typically
changing slowly over time and the
question is how do you model that stuff
in the data warehouse and here on these
images I have some antiquated ETL drag
and drop tools where people would drag
and drop their logic supposed to write
in code I don't know how they would
check that into github but those that
are the early days of ETL and data
warehousing and people would drag and
drop stuff and they try to get to these
slowly changing dimension type - which
I'm gonna get all about so this today is
all it's not only about functional data
engineering it's also a little bit of a
primer on antiquated approach - to
slowly change in dimension and how to
model change in your dimensions so this
is taken out of the Wikipedia page about
slowly changing dimension to set a very
simple examples that that illustrate you
know the different types of approaches
to slowly changing dimensions I know
this is really small maybe people can't
read very well so fully you can read
enough I'll try to read for you here so
the first approach slowly changing
dimension type one is where you would
simply override
the data so here we're looking at a
supplier dimension so picture your big
business and you have a you know
suppliers and you want to structure all
your suppliers into a specific dem
supplier dimension and then one of your
supplier moves so ABC Acme supply
supplier moves from Illinois to
California the first approach is just to
say let's do as if this customer always
live in California was always in
California we're just going to update
the dimension table we'll update that
cell and now this supplier was always in
California of course if you're doing
your taxes that's probably not gonna fly
very well so you know someone's going to
be like we need to keep track of that
history and the second approach that the
slow change dimension you know in the
books that you'd read about is the type
2 the type 2 approach is to add a new
row so given the supplier code which is
ABC and the natural key would go and
create a surrogate key 1 2 4 and you
would price start managing the effective
date and your dimension table saying for
this time period this is the state of
where my supplier is and not only you
need to do like extra management of this
dimension and slightly complicated
it's full of mutations also when you
when you load up your fact tables you
need to do what they call a surrogate
key lookup which is kind of complex and
expensive and your FAQ table also will
be filled with surrogate keys that are
slightly unreadable I need to make sure
this computer it is not going sleep mode
again but yeah so so you have to do
these surrogate key lookups it's fairly
complicated in full of mutations the
type 3 approach is kind of kind of a
half-ass approach where you would create
a new column and keep some sort of
version of history or what you think is
important about a change in time so
these approaches have a lot of
shortcomings the type one approach is
full of mutation you you lose history
right if you run the same query today
and yesterday and you're gonna get
different results there's no way to know
where that supplier was in the past
in a lot of cases that's not what you
need and if you think that's what you
need now that's not what you might need
in the future and you're gonna have to
go back and remodel stuff and reload
your data and mutate your data and
that's no good the type 2 is effectively
super hard to manage it makes loading
your dimensions harder makes loading
your facts sardar and it makes you kind
of forced to do a lot of up certs and
complex ETL it's also not a given that
you're gonna fall back on your feet if
you if you were to say wipe the
dimension table and try to go back to
the state that you were in you might not
get exactly there unfortunately
so type 3 is kind of a bad compromise
and type and so people over time came up
with slowly change dimension type 4 type
6 like people didn't know what to invent
anymore these are all kind of the same
nonsense or a similar version of
composite version of that nonsense so
what is the functional approach to
dealing with changes in your dimension
is super simple it's just to simply
snapshot all the data so that means that
you're dim supplier for each day for
each one of your ETL schedule you're
going to create a full snapshot of the
dimension table as it was that day so
that means that you might have you know
if you have like three years ten years
worth of data you would have you know
thousands or tens of thousand have
duplicated data in your dimensions that
sounds awful right you're like well
you're deployed max your duplicate this
data it's slowly changing yet you store
kind of the whole thing every day that's
kind of insane well so there's there's a
few things about this that that I want
to say that kind of mitigates the this
approach so first is storage is cheap
compute is cheap there's virtually no
limit there so that's one point then you
have the fact that dimension dimensional
data in relationship to facts is usually
very small and simple so that means that
your supplier let's say your company as
a hundred supplier or a thousand
supplier even if it's like if
if your company has a million suppliers
thinking snapshots of a million rows
nowadays in bigquery presto and Paulo
hive is drop in a bucket
really and that there's also the thing
where storage is cheap engineering
timings expensive this mental model is a
lot easier to reason about it allows you
to have good reproducibility which is
invaluable
so these trade-offs are trade-offs you
might decide to make or not make but
this is kind of the best we have and it
happens to work very well in places like
Facebook and Airbnb if you want to sort
here to kind of prove my point that the
mental model is easy you can see that if
you want to do a query joining your
factory dimension all you need to do is
join on the key and forced force the the
latest partition so it's pretty common
now to have macros and your sequel tools
that will allow you to do things like
that another approach is to maintain a
view say that would be called dim
supplier current that would always point
to the latest partition of your supplier
dimension problem solved now if you want
if you're interested in the attribute of
the dimension member at the time of the
transaction what you what you need to do
is simply join on the key and join on
the partitioning date key problem solved
there's also a nice byproduct of snap
shutting your dimension is the fact that
now you can start doing time series
against your dimensional data snapshot
so that means dim supplier it could be
if you want to count how many suppliers
you've had over time you could just say
so I count star from supplier group by
date and and you can do a new family of
queries that perhaps or not that easy
before what it slowly changed in
dimension type to that are fairly easy
to do now so if you ever hear about
slowly changing dimension again you can
just say all that stuff is absolute I
heard about at a conference let me point
you to an article and done you can just
kind of wash it off
and so now I'm going to talk about
late-arriving facts and keep an eye on
my watch - so late arriving facts are
common right I think that people at
Apache beam have been beating that horse
for a while one thing that's important
about late-arriving facts is that you
need to essentially have two time
dimensions in your data warehouse if you
have late-arriving facts you need event
time and event processing time if you
care about immutability and lending your
stuff in your staging area and not
touching it ever again and compressing
it indexing it into RC files or park'
files you need to close the loop on on
DS so you need to essentially partition
on event processing time so only if you
were to partition based on event time
you would have to wait for the window to
close it would take longer you have to
have more data in memory so as much as
you can partition on your event
processing time so you can close the
loop partition pruning might be lost so
the partition pruning is this thing that
database the database optimizers do
where if you apply a predicate like a
date filter on a partition field the
database is going to only scan a subset
of the partitions so knowing that most
queries that analysts and data
scientists and people in general will
fire will be predicated on event time
and now you are partitioned on event
processing time you might not be able to
do partition pruning anymore so here
what you what you lose out there are
ways to mitigate this
so first is you can somewhat rely on
execution engine optimization so if
you're using Park it files or our C
files the execution engine as it hits a
certain Park it block it's going to read
the footer and see oh there's no event
like for the event time I'm looking for
there's really nothing in that block for
me so the damage is not that good you're
scanning more partitions but you're
effectively scanning more Parque footers
and you're skipping the blocks in a lot
of cases you can all
to instruct people to apply predicates
on partition fields knowing your
analysts and data scientists that
probably won't happen but you know you
can always have hope that it may happen
you can also swap partition by event
time right so if you know that your
partition you want a partition by by
event processing time because you know
it's important to close up the loop you
could could sub partition on sub
partition on event time then you get
maybe best of both worlds but more files
in your warehouse that's a trade off and
you can also like if you have a lot of
time predicated queries you could also
pivot so maybe your staging area is
partitioned by by the event processing
time but maybe later on in your ETL you
rebuild a certain window of data that
know that you know might change and you
repartition the data by event time in
those fact tables all right next topic I
want to talk about is self or past
dependencies and saying that those
should be avoided at all times or not at
all times whenever you can so what are
self or past dependencies so let's say
we agree that we you should snap shut
your dimensional your dimension data
right so I spoke earlier about you
should just create a new partition
everyday for your dimensions one thing
that might seem really natural would be
to take yesterday's say your dim
supplier take yesterday's dim supplier
and apply a set of changes or operations
that might have happened today and use
that to load the next partition and the
point I want to make here is that
there's this thing that I just kind of
made up that's called complexity score
so a proxy for the complexity of your
ETL might be how many partitions were
necessary to compute this partition
right so if you're if you're loading dim
user from your database scrape then you
might be just scanning a handful of
partition and that's really easy to
recreate and reason about and parallel
eyes if you use dim user to create them
user so that means that if you want to
backfill this you're gonna have to do it
sequentially and go very far in the past
and your complexity score for that
partition goes up the roof so one of the
reason why people might want to do
things like self or past dependencies in
their ETL is because you might have
cumulative metrics or time windowed
metrics some things some things like at
lift it might be really great to have
like a total number of rides for the
customer you know in the customer table
that's something that's super useful but
I would argue that dough that metric is
useful maybe it should not live in a
dimension right should metrics live in
dimensions perhaps maybe sometimes but
if you're going to compute it I would I
would in general say please make sure
you don't do a self or pass dependency
and rely on a specialized framework that
would be good and optimized and
efficient at computing cumulative or
windowed metrics know for unfortunately
this is like out the scope of this talk
for me to talk about a specialized
framework that would achieve this I know
those things are fairly common I should
probably blog about it at some point and
I'll be at office hour next in the next
hour if people want to talk about this
topic specifically now I want to talk
about file explosion so I know at Airbnb
we were like partitioning everything
right and sometimes sub part in sub
partitioning things and that leads to
that leads to a lot of files in HDFS or
in s3 or whatever storage you use for
your data warehouse you know each
partition as at least one file and if
part if you partition the hell out of
everything that your Hadoop name node or
HDFS or s3 somehow will suffer at some
point because we have this explosion of
files so there are some ways to mitigate
this one is to be careful around sub
partitioning and perhaps being careful
about and having short schedule
intervals right like hourly hourly is
probably okay five minutes starts you
start to get a lot of files you know if
you're if you do things on a five minute
type window there's also this idea that
you could compile
later earlier partition so if you have
you know multiple years worth of data
and you partition by day perhaps
2010-2011 maybe all the way to 2000 you
know 16 you can you can kind of assemble
these partitions into less partitions
I'm not going to get much deeper into
this that's something to keep in mind
because it's a byproduct of this
approach that's somewhat undesirable or
that needs to be handled or mitigated so
I'm already getting into the conclusion
portion of this so that I've got two
points I want to make around my
conclusion first is that times have
changed a lot since the original book on
data warehousing were written right and
the landscape and the technology
landscape has completely changed and we
need someone to to go and rewrite these
books I like to write code I don't like
to write books I'm not going to rewrite
these books but I think some of the core
things that I've changed that really
changed the methodology of how a data
warehouse should be built and I want to
talk about briefly one is we have cheap
limitless storage distributed database
the distributed databases that is
virtually infinite compute so we have
seen the rise of read up to my stores an
immutable file format right at the time
where these books were written people
had Oracle databases that were these
stores that are like effectively super
super mutable you can go and change any
cell and you have transaction and all
that stuff nowadays if you're using
presto hive Impala bigquery Athena
whatever you use you're like the data is
stored in these immutable segments that
are indexed encoded compressed column
knives and you know the practice of
going and updating stuff and mutating
data not as easy anymore but in return
you get these like read up to my stores
that are really good at data warehousing
and another thing I would like to point
out that has changed is that the time
where these books were written you had
small teams of highly specialized data
professional building the warehouse for
the
company I think that's not true anymore
I think everyone is taking part in the
computation data warehousing process nor
at least of the companies that I've
worked over the past five or six years
and everyone is welcome to use and
create and mute and change and shape the
future of the data warehouse in the data
in the company now the last point I want
to make is first learn the rules and
then break them so that's you know any
methodology whether it's object-oriented
programming functional programming
whether it is this functional data
engineering thing I'm talking about and
it's good to know the rules but I'm sure
in your environments you have all sorts
of reasons to go and make up your own
rules break those rules and as long as
you know why that you're disgracing and
why you are it's usually the good thing
to do so thank you everyone that's all
I'll be in the office our next door so
thank you we have time for questions
hi thanks really nice talk I really like
the perspective on kind of taking a full
snapshot of your your dimensions every
time but the question I have about that
is if you if you're doing that don't you
run the risk of turning what could be
like a small data problem that fits in a
Postgres warehouse to a big data problem
but this is how you get into big data
right by generating data you don't need
so so I would say for all I think it's a
no-brainer for all of the very small
dimensions right then supplier if it's a
hundred or thousand rows a day
I just don't bother don't do any complex
modeling just snapshot your dimensions
if you work at Facebook and you're
dealing with a user dimension you might
want to rethink that a little bit
because you have billions of rows that
you're duplicating every day though I've
seen I've seen it done like when it
becomes the practice people are so used
to that mental model and the uniformity
then we're used to say working with with
hive and park in the Menace store people
will will just kind of move forward with
this that doesn't mean that for larger
dimensions you cannot do a mix of
techniques right so what you could do is
you could say for my larger dimension I
want to apply some of the concepts of
the type to dimension or I might want to
have lower retentions for for these
tables or I might want to do what I
would call vertical partitioning which
would be trying to keep as much as
possible the fields that might fit
nicely in your dimension into some sort
of fact or some sort of like user metric
type fact table so I would say the way
to mitigate this is to keep maybe your
dimension table a little bit thinner
less fields model your data differently
and maybe in some cases if it makes
sense to go with a type 2 approach you
know where where it makes more most
sense
I really like your approach to kind of
the persistent staging area but let's
say hypothetically a regulator in Europe
decides that people can request to be
forgotten how do you sort of deal with
that situation so you can come and work
at lift where we don't really have a
Europe branch just yet so we don't
really have to deal with that right just
now
or maybe we do I don't know I'm not
really good at legal things so I think I
think you probably at some point need to
anonymize your data I'm not sure if it's
enough to anonymize your data so then
you know I know it's common for
companies to have a retention and an
enemy's Animas ation framework so that
means that you would add metadata to
your table properties saying this table
contains non-anonymous data and needs to
be anonymized you can't have a frame a
framework that knows about the fields
that it needs to encrypt hash and then
to have this background process kind of
like a demon that comes looks at the
table and folds them on themselves so
moves the immutable partition into an
anonymized equivalent that partition and
works in the background and tries to
respect all the rules so that's the best
I can explain here not and I don't know
what the legal constraints are exactly
but I know it's common to have these
anonymization frameworks just one ask
question about item potency it's real
important in pipelines to do things once
with idempotency you have any comments
on item potency in email pipelines so
pipeline so instance you need to you
know perhaps you build an aggregation
your aggregate you sending data you
build a report and then you need to hit
a list what you want to make sure
somehow that you only sent them once for
whatever reason real life story we were
sending out emails we sent out a few
thousand a day we had a problem with our
open TS DB client or just accessing it
and so after the email was sent out
there was a failure with the TS DB
metrics right and as a result the job
was failing and our version of air flow
and so we kept redoing it not ending
multiple emails at same
exactly yeah I think I think that you
know so what one thing is like what when
you're sending an email to someone that
is not an idempotent operation or maybe
the function that sends the email itself
needs to have some sort of memory and
UUID some sort of unique identifier
saying like when I send an email and now
I'm not talking about the idempotent
data warehouse function I'm talking
about I didn't put an email sending
function that would say something like
did I ever send this email before with
this UUID and if you know and if so do
not send it again or so the idempotent
function is send this email if it was
never sent before and somehow you need
to keep track in memory of what you've
sent or not in the past
you